that's gum right but it's better Pat so
actually wasn't going to upload videos
today but I was sent a quick demo of the
dying light which is a game I've been
really looking forward to it looks very
very cool I don't want to talk too much
about it I just kind of want to get into
it right away say we go
so I think you see there's like parkour
guys in the background from all the
zombies and I guess some people were
describing is as mirrors edge meets Dead
Island I guess and birds I talked to one
of my favorite games and you can't go
wrong with adding any thing to zombies
sir all right so we're gonna watch a
movie while running uh-huh hold okay
sure
that's that sounds fair okay sure to
move around the world freely okay okay
this is a game I want to play with the
oculus hell yeah
so this is a very very late I don't even
think I don't even know what version of
the game this is very burly and so there
will be a lot of bugs
don't don't don't be hatin on this
skating okay do we get to play mind GOC
whatever this girl that is
manlet yes can you break insults me cool
oh my god is here bras
come on sorry sorry I don't mean to
sobbing hello
you okay - hello here's pouting ha ha ha
whoa so sorry man oh is this a be cool
lane is it awesome
what is happening what is going on here
anyone else
anyone else want the axe no bunch of
[ __ ] if you happy and you know it
climb up if you have been you know it
climb a pole if you happen you know it
any really want to go if you happen
enroll in Kalama fall hey all right cool
there has to be something in the air
fairness okay good job
nah what are you doing here bro where's
I'll go rid of it are you hurt
he's right there by the way there we go
just my heart's racing
thank you thank you that will be $200
thank you very much you're gonna help
yourself out I'll be on my way now sir
all right what do we go now this is
awesome can jump on walls and [ __ ] oh my
god oh my god I'm awesome
Oh whew oh [ __ ] it's right there what is
that what okay I better go there
Yolo oh my god I'm the best [ __ ] the
rest eat the hest
on my chest okay we're saying that
what what oh [ __ ] he's down there should
I help him what is this a supply crate
the demos about to run out come on uh
okay uh oh it's like Oh auntie doesn't
[ __ ] cooled maybe not I don't [ __ ]
know okay let's help him don't worry
you're fine you're fine papa pizzas here
feel no fear I don't know huh uh uh
sorry shine on you
hello sir oh yeah welcome
I was skirmishing for supplies here well
you didn't do a good jobs
I brought the door trapping myself
inside hey toilet thank you if not for
you I do one of them right now let me
repay the favor alright then let me just
be ready okay I'm ready
what what are you Oh cash of course
Thank You that'll be two hundred out all
right let's go to the oh [ __ ]
that thing is like the coolest thing
ever
what am i doing I sorry I suck at this
game whoa
okay I'm starting to learn a little back
feels awesome I hope I can make it over
there in time though look at that [ __ ]
how awesome how badass is that
oh god it's right down here oh [ __ ] Wow
oh don't go on the floor don't go on the
floor oh oh oh don't worry don't mind me
sir don't mind me I'm just I'll be on my
way where the [ __ ] is it oh god oh god
it's so terrifying being on the floor
and hearing them go up go up go up ah ha
ha uh is it on the roof
Oh check the last alright I only have oh
cool
Yolo hell yeah [ __ ] bring it on [ __ ]
I don't know why I'm fighting you but I
star shine shine shine shine what what
are you shot shot yet ha ha oh man I
suck so bad
good night good luck day night all right
cool
I like that that was fun I wish I could
play more it sucks this is just like
gonna them or or whatever all right
well all in good time I hope you both
enjoy watching let me know if you think
this is something we should keep playing
and I'll see you tomorrow
sails and breasts love you
you